tutti ragazzi e premete sono meglio sono
bravi j
oggi siamo tornati su ball che cosa
amiche ho cliccato poiché già partiamo
de merda fantastico siamo madonna che
pronunciarla thibaud buyers come gara
belga
io ho già fatto fuori l'altro tizio e ho
sbloccato il tizio in cucina anche
sarebbe lui allora il nostro
nell'episodio precedente in cucina c'era
mia nonna
addio che cazzo di fine hai fatto fare a
mia nonna altedo mena terreno e meno coi
coltelli sforzo di un attimo che devo
prendere i coltelli per ucciderti bravo
hai dei tormentoni giustamente quando
uno sta per morire
[Musica]
che cazzo liriche tra i dieci coltelli
in faccia infatti non lo so perché
ragazzi si è messo a vita non ho idea è
scemo non ha un senso mago ok non è
comunque a parte le uccisioni
la teiera iera più
estintore maniera più olio d hiver delle
vergini coatings tagliare il tagliere il
la pentola il ferro da stiro e che cazzo
ne so io e lo cucina uso la tagliata in
filone alcun non lo so cos'è successo
cos'è cosa che so clicca fermi
cosa è successo a la teiera andava con
l'estintore non ho capito meno con casa
l'ho usata non ho capito bene
cinque minuti dopo il suo successo e mi
sognerei per cortesia al tempo stavo
scherzando va bene lo faccio io debba
glass fantastici ragazzi non ho capito
con cosa ho utilizzato la teiera
potrebbe essere un problema
bleach ok blitz primo dragon ball più
one piece il lavandino ah ecco bleach ep
lavandino ma per chi prende sempre
l'estintore non l'ho toccato l'estintore
perché prendere estinto ma va beh
spiegami il senso che cosa dovrebbe fare
il marigliano amico ma in realtà è così
che funziona il nostro lindo ragazzi
quando versate il mastro lindo denti in
lamiera calcio un uomo invisibile che
prende un altro uomo invisibile e lo
infila nel tubo della vandinho a
sgorgare non lo sapevo io questo
fantastico altro metodo per dimagrire
ragazzi non serve un cazzo la dieta
mettete il detersivo e infilata la
faccia vedi che diventi magro 3 su 13
regala la padella fa della 2 padelli
queste armi di distruzione di massa
andrebbero abolite
ok che bello sembra cosa mister game and
works ferro da stiro caldo facciamo
serata stira grattugia più ferro da
stiro grattugia qui ferro da stiro più
olio dei rei delle vergini o caso mi sa
che l'olio delle vergini ha sbagliato e
questo rolling ping che cazzo air one al
mattarello ciò ma stare e perché prendi
la pentola non l'ho toccata all'aperto
va beh torniamo al ladro che ritrovato
sembra mister satan me ne sono accorta
del con questo ci contiamo una pasta
stasera col mattarello perfetto bello è
sicuramente più bello di prima zero vedi
come lucido in faccia lavatrice ragazzi
la lavatrice più tagliere più olio delle
vergini la sacca poi voglio vedere che
questo come saranno le mutande sporche
della palestra sicuro dentro dentro la
lavatrice anche sul detersivo per
lavatrice giusto ce l'hai la morbida ora
come preoccupato cometti anche
l'ammorbidente perché sono i capi
l'antico tratto credo che si stia
divertendo non so perché io sto
presentimento finito ma lei sotto la
chiappa colore perché se non un babbo
ragazzi e
che credo che abbia capito come funziona
io non la so fare l'attrice però credo
di avere imparato e se la sacca la sacca
più e che sua sacca più lavandino
buttiamola la roba nel lavandino giusto
[Musica]
il diamante duramente ai tre giocare la
bambina lo gridato no perché tutti gli
amanti e lavoro però però lo capisco
effettivamente perché a trovarne di
diamanti
minecraft io farei così il vostro posso
farti una domanda giusto per capire cioè
nel lavandino cioè un frullatore con che
cazzo di lavandino a c'è un qualche cosa
che frulla nel lavandino non so perché
ma va bene no forse non l'aveva usato
bello frulliamo gli la testa a posto e
frullate un bravo a posto se ci sei
aggiungi del ghiaccio e della banana che
facciamo un bel frappe bravissimo foto
su tredici ragazzi facciamo la cucina
più l'olio olonio da l'amore di dio è
servito a qualcosa sto cazzo di olio
bello ti piace e la fidata e l'olio del
motore e zio ladro al rosso l'avevo
letta osta ricetta su
giallo zafferano una volta si cuoce così
ragazzi 45 minuti dopo giustamente si è
cotto buono ragazzi croccante melo mi
piace con the croccante tagliere
tagliere il caso del ghiaccio no
tagliere coltelli ha giustamente
tagliere con che cosa vale ovvio a
pensavi che trova ad essi dare in testa
in realtà mi serviva solo perché devo
tagliare i pomodori mettersi la mano li
per cortesia bravo e grazie a noi
abbiamo finito metti subito la sua zampa
lo ridà sul bravo vedo che capisce
ragazzi mi piace quando capisci cervello
12 facciamo il jus del 10 su 13 mancano
manca 3 che non ho ben capito come doni
farli la porta accuse c'è un ripostiglio
addio è figlia che botta nel ripostiglio
devi andare bravo il progetto che la
madonna riccione a ripostiglio mozilla
48 ore dopo una settimana dopo
come fa essere vivo con come fa mangiare
ea bere un mese dopo è ancora vivo uno
zombie come fa a essere vivo e possibile
hanno mangiato né bevuto o ci avevo
provviste non so non poteva fare subito
così invece di aspettare un anno
io sono qui che aspetto sa dove andare
avanti non l'ho capito che ispira a
veroli che aspettare che finisce di
dargli le botte ma continuerà così in
eterno e manca due ragazzi che non ho
capito quali sono
ma credo siano spetta oddio ho sbagliato
che cazzo applicato
no non mi far iniziare lurido ho
sbagliato a cliccare io ero in cucina
continua oggi grazie a 10 dal continuo
allestitore non ancora osato è vero ecco
infatti adesso l'ho usato perfetto a
posto zio è in realtà questa è no stavo
scherzando a questa parte nella best a
nessuno non l'ha vista non fate voi non
avete visto niente di questa cosa
ragazzi ma anche a una cosa non ho
capito che cosa devo fare per ho capito
che centra cosi non e ghiaccio questo
sicuro il frisé era freezer c'è anche
bleach c'era tutto oggi allora questo
destino
cinque minuti dopo ovviamente a 5 nuti
dopo lo ficcato nel frigo con fuori solo
i capelli 48 ore dopo
cosa facciamo prendiamo facciamo apriamo
la gelateria guscio cadavere no a ok
scusa non avevo dubbi ma buono ragazzi
credo di aver finito
credo master murder euphon dal combo kit
ce l'ho fatta ho vinto the savage the
bug l'arma un cazzo vuol dire sei punti
da button fest a devo cliccare sui cosi
abbiamo far sgranare ladra giu
carino quindi ragazzi questo in teoria
il finale perfetto ok devo cliccare
velocemente in modo che wii schiamazzi
ladro ovvio ammazza ho visto che schifo
hanno preso tutto facile sembra facile
non è facile ma morto ho vinto bravo
whisky bravo vista e adesso da bravo
pulisci tutto perché poi lo dico alla
nonna congratulation jefferies defender
di roma games altri badoo.com in next
web serial killer fantastico quindi
ragazzi nel prossimo episodio ci sarà
maltratta serial killer per ora va bene
così tanto siete bellissimi credete in
siete veramente dei figli vede ragazzi
spero che video vi sia piaciuto a casa
il tutto video è piaciuta come non mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
condivido a trattare iniziale senza il
sì di skype e ci vediamo al prossimo
video della ragazza